THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ARE DOING
TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
JOINING US NOW IS ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" LIST.
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER.
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
I HAD TO TALK THIS MAN INTO
DOING RADIO.
THIS IS A FACT.
I MADE HIM DO IT.
HE WAS RELUCTANT AND RESISTANT.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOU IS YOUR
BRAIN MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
YOU ARE A GREAT CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR.
I WORRIED ABOUT A REPUBLIC AFTER
I SAW TODAY.
I'VE BEEN WORRIED FOR A WHILE.
>> AS FAR AS ROBERT MUELLER GOE
GOES, HE WAS IN NO CONDITION TO
TESTIFY, BUT ON THE OTHER HAND,
HE WAS ON NO HANDS TO BE ON THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE VICTIM HERE IS NOT MUELLER.
THE VICTIM IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
I WANT PEOPLE TO KEEP SOMETHING
IN MIND.
IT WAS A PROSECUTOR'S BRIEF.
IT WAS THEIR BEST SHOT.
THERE IS NO REPLY REPORT BY THE
PRESIDENT THAT WAS SUPPORTED.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
NO CROSS EXAMINATIONS, NO
CHALLENGES OF ANY TYPE.
SO THIS IS A REALLY SOVIET STYLE
PROCESS WE ARE GOING THROUGH.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE THEY WILL
REVEAL THEMSELVES AS THE CROWNS
THAT THEY TRULY ARE.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WERE TRULY
INTERESTED IN OVERWHELMING
RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
CAMPAIGN, THEN WHY DIDN'T YOU
CALL BARACK OBAMA?
DOMINIC AND JOE BIDEN TO TESTIF
TESTIFY?
THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ALLOWED
THE RUSSIANS TO HAVE
OVERWHELMING INFLUENCE IN OUR
CAMPAIGN, AND THEY KEPT THEIR
MOUTH SHUT, BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
HILARY WOULD WIN.
WHERE ANY OF THEM?
THAT'S THAT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
THESE LIBERAL DEMOCRATS WHO RAN
THIS OPERATION ARE SUCH
INCOMPETENT.
THEY CITED THREE STATUTES THAT
DON'T APPLY.
MOREOVER, WHAT DOCUMENT DID THE
PRESIDENT IMPOSE.
WHAT RESOURCES TO THE PRESIDENT
WITHHOLD?
NOT ONE.
NO CONSPIRACY, NO OBSTRUCTION.
LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT OBSTRUCTION.
>> Sean: WE GOT ABOUT 45
SECONDS.
>> IT'S TOO LATE THEN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MULLER'S
PURVIEW.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
RUSSIA'S ROLE.
THE FISA APPLICATIONS,
MEDICAID'S COUP ATTEMPT.
FBI PLACING SPIES ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
UNMASKING OF CITIZENS.
ALL OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW.
WE NEVER HEARD THE END OF IT.
>> I'M DONE BROTHER.
>> Sean: THERE ARE ONLY A
COUPLE OF US WHO PUT OUR NECK
OUT FROM THE BEGINNING ON THIS.